Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Die Sonne scheint, die Vögellein zwitschern, ich komme langsam in Campingstimmung.
Machen wir doch einen Camp.
Da machen wir doch ein Camp. Das passt ganz gut äh hier als,
vorbereitet, genau. Pünktlich zu äh Logbuch äh äh Netzpolitik einhundertfünfundvierzig, welches die Sendung ist, die ihr gerade hört,
Äh können wir verkünden, dass es ein Camp geben wird. Das ist natürlich jetzt keine wirkliche Neuigkeiten. Das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal fallen gelassen, aber jetzt kann man auch Tickets kaufen.
Jetzt kann man die Tickets kaufen, ja,
Also Camp äh vom dreizehnten bis siebzehnten August im Ziegeleipark Mildenberg im äh erweiterten Umland Berlins,
Ticketverkauf ist gestartet,
vor zwei Tagen, glaube ich, am Montag. Ähm die Tickets sind natürlich äh wie einige bemerkt haben nicht besonders günstig.
Das liegt mit den ähm hohen, man hängt mit den hohen Aufwendungen zusammen, die notwendig sind, um ein solches Camp zu ermöglichen. Es gibt da auch auf der,
ähm auf der Vorverkaufsseite so schöne Grafen, wo drin steht, wie viel,
benötigt wird, um dieses Event stattfinden zu lassen. Und natürlich haben wir auch wieder unterschiedliche Ticketpreise,
wo es dann eben einen äh Standardpreis äh gibt, der für diese vier Tage Camping mit,
Programm auf zwei Zelten und hasse alles nicht gesehen bei zweihundert äh zwanzig Euro liegt. Dann gibt's halt den leicht ermäßigsten Preis von zweihundert und den noch.
Ermäßigteren Preis von einhundertachtzig und für diejenigen, für die das jetzt
dann trotzdem noch eine eine zu hohe Belastung darstellt, gibt's dann eine E-Mail-Adresse, an die man sich wenden kann,
seine Situation darlegen kann und man sich dann sicherlich auch einig wird.
Also am Ende äh muss halt beides funktionieren. Man muss halt die Community zusammenbekommen, die man dort auch haben will, aber am Ende
Ich glaube, man kann sich
nur sehr schwer eine Vorstellung davon machen, was für eine logistische und finanzielle Belastung so eine Veranstaltung ist. Das Camp war schon immer eine Risikoveranstaltung und ähm ist
dieses Mal auch sonderlich schwer einzuschätzen, weil einfach die letzten Kongresse so durch die Decke gegangen sind und man dann,
Intuitiv auch gleich mit so einem Run rechnet, den aber auch überhaupt nicht äh quantifizieren kann und dann so in dieser,
Problemzone steckt, dass man,
Auf der einen Seite gar nicht so genau weiß, wie viel Leute werden wir, aber die Infrastruktur schon seit langem auf eine bestimmte Zahl hin,
getrimmt ist und eben dann am Ende auch nur sehr wenig Varianz hat, also allein Wasserversorgung und Wasserentsorgung vor allem.
Ähm ist da äh sehr problematisch, also deutlich problematischer zum Beispiel als Strom,
Kriegt man einfach eskaliert, da kann man nochmal einen Generator da hinstellen, dann hat man einfach mehr. Ja, aber bei Wasser, da hat das einfach mit äh Durchschlussmengen zu tun und die sind eben nicht so ohne weiteres äh,
ohne jetzt zu viel hier über Camp, Organisationsdetails zu weinen, freuen wir uns alle, dass wir jetzt überhaupt erstmal so weit gekommen sind. Es gibt also,
Tickets, holt euch welche, kommt aufs Camp, denn da gibt's dann einiges Interessantes zu sehen.
Man kann ja auch noch zum Trost sagen, es ist halt wirklich nicht, dass man da einfach irgendwo auf einen leeren Acker fährt und äh dann,
dann steht man da halt, ne? Also das ist halt eine Veranstaltung mit einem riesen Programm. Ich habe jetzt gerade mal hier den Taschenrechner gezückt. Äh,
Steht ja hier sehr transparent, das kostet halt eine Millionen. Knapp.
Und äh das ist bei der äh Anzahl an äh Besuchern, die wir dort empfangen können, bevor wir
über unsere feuerrechtlichen Auflagen hinaus äh gehen
ist das dann halt ungefähr dieser durchschnittliche Ticketpreis. Aber es gibt ja auch diesen schönen Graf, der den durchschnittlichen Ticketpreis anzeigt und da sind äh durchaus sehr viele Menschen, die,
äh sich bereit erklärt haben, ein äh sogar noch einen größeren,
Betrag zu zahlen, nämlich die Supporter-Tickets zu nehmen, um eben auch anderen den Besuch der Veranstaltung zu ermöglichen.
Ja, ich finde das eine super Idee. Also so eine Grafik anzuzeigen, die äh automatisch visualisiert, wie derzeit so die Bereitschaft ist, äh über den Schnitt zu gehen. Das äh.
Ist halt scheiße für die schwarze Kasse, aber.
Nein, ähm.
So ist das mit der Transparenz.
Ist super. Ansonsten,
Ansonsten natürlich, okay, Camp ist natürlich, aber wir haben ja schon ein bisschen davon erzählt, ne, Camp ist ein ein Community Event und man weiß, äh es ist, glaube ich, auch nicht so sehr, also es ist mehr nach innen gerichtet, als jetzt diese Kongresse, ja.
Aber du bist eigentlich nicht so richtig gut informiert, was das Camp ist, ne.
Willst du mir erzählen? Okay, sorry. Hat fast geklappt.
Ja.
Es gilt natürlich nach wie vor, äh, wiederum alle vier Jahre den Kontakt zu Herz aus Gold äh aufzubauen, die halt regelmäßig äh in den Orbit des Planeten Erde eintritt,
vollständig getan, selbstverständlich, ja?
Deswegen hat das so bisher auch noch keiner äh berichtet, aber dem CCC liegen wie immer sehr gesicherte Erkenntnisse vor. Über die Quellen dürfen wir nicht so ohne weiteres reden, aber das ist einfach mal Spacehacking äh Deluxe,
die Verbindung zum Weltraum ist sichergestellt. Ich meine, der TCC ist äh eine eine galaktische Vereinigung, ja. Nein, galaktisch.
Dinos wieder in die Satzung des Chaos Computer C.
Steht nicht in der Satzung.
Sicherlich. Tue ich dir das.
Ich lese keine Satzungen.
Lies mal die Satzung, da steht's nämlich drin. Und da steht galaktisch. Doch.
Werden sie nun Zeuge.
Ich bin schon länger in diesem Club.
Das ist jetzt, ne, das ist diese diese, also solche Leute übrigens, ne? Wer wer da hinkommt, um irgendwie solche Sprüche zu bringen,
der kann auch gerne zu Hause bleiben. Wir wollen da äh gemeinsam äh schöne Zeit verbringen und angeben könnt ihr woanders,
Gerade auch wieder, sorry so das Ding. Äh es wurde jetzt auch die Programm Einreichung und Ablehnung verschickt. Äh die Programm,
Einreichungszusagen und Ablehnungen verschickt, wie bei jeder CCC-Veranstaltung ist es äh leider äh notwendig, dass ein größerer Teil der Einreichung eben nicht angenommen werden kann,
das ist einfach ne? Sonst müsste das müsste die Veranstaltung noch teurer werden
Und äh wir noch mehr Zelte aufbauen und so weiter. Das heißt, wir sind gezwungen, viele sehr gute hochkarätige Einreichungen abzulehnen. Und da gibt's dann auch immer wieder so schöne Mails, ne.
Kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass ihr meine, ich bin aber hier der hasse nicht gesehen und äh wenn wenn ihr das jetzt hier der Community, dann weiß ich ja, dann geht also,
könnte, das ist ja eine Katastrophe, dass ihr meinen meinen großartigen Vortrag eurer Community vorenthalten wollt.
Wir berechnen die Parabel äh des Fluges, des kleinen zusammengeknüllten Papiers in den Weg, auf den den Papierkorb.
Ich ich bin doch so der, ich bin echt gespannt. Das ist dann immer so, wo du denkst so, boah gut, darf er den abgelehnt haben?
Prä-Ampel. Die Informationsgesellschaft unserer Tage ist ohne Computer nicht mehr denkbar. Die Einsatzmöglichkeiten der automatisierten Datenverarbeitung und Datenübermittlung bergen Chancen, aber auch Gefahren für den Einzelnen und für die Gesellschaft.
Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologien verändern das Verhältnis Mensch Maschine und der Menschen untereinander. Die Entwicklung zur Informationsgesellschaft erfordert ein neues Menschenrecht auf weltweite ungehinderte Kommunikation.
Der Chaos Computerclub ist eine galaktische Gemeinschaft von Lebewesen, unabhängig von Alter, Geschlecht und Rasse sowie gesellschaftlicher Stellung, die sich grenzüberschreitend für Informationsfreiheit.
Zensur, Zensur.
Für Informationsfreiheit einsetzt und mit den Auswirkungen von Technologien auf die Gesellschaft sowie das einzelne Lebewesen beschäftigt und das Wissen um diese Entwicklung fördert. Und das natürlich auch mit Mitteln des Camps.
Wir wir verbuchen das jetzt hier unter nicht unter Besserwisserei, sondern unter.
Ups, sondern.
Ähm Allgemeinbildung.
Genau, das war die Präambel des.
Lernt, lernt die Präambel des CCC, damit euch nicht in einem live Podcast passiert, dass ihr intergalaktisch sagt, wo nur galaktisch hier hingehört, ja, weil das ist übrigens möchte ich auch,
kritisieren diese äh Form von Intergalaktophobie,
Das ist eine Ausgrenzung,
Das ist einfach eine Ausgrenzung.
Der Universale Rassismus. Ja, ja. Na ja, kein Laktismus ist das.
Galaktismus. Ach nee, die was ist, wie heißt unsere Galaxie nochmal? Sag mal, wie heißt die Nummer? Das ist Mischhas ist die Galaxie, ne? So. Milch-Rassismus. Ist das nämlich.
Ja, ist das. Kannst du jetzt so.
Na ja, wir sind alle nicht frei davon. Macht ihr das mal klar?
Du merkst das nur nicht mehr. Du merkst das nur nicht mehr.
Tja.
Wie kamen wir nochmal auf dieses Camp? Ach ja, der Tim ist äh lass mal. Der Tim äh hat sich einen neuen Stuhl gekauft und er wird ihn einsetzen beim ähm beim Camp, denn wir podcasten ja eben sitzen.
Und wir werden das dann auch beim Camp tun. Wir wir haben einen Podcast und wir werden ihn benutzen und äh wir wissen aber noch nicht, in welchem Rahmen, wo und wann. Also in Millenberg.
Genau, aber es wird, es wird ein Lokbuch auf dem Camp äh geben. Und so ja, denn jetzt euch endlich durchgerungen habt, euch das Ticket zu klicken. Wir werden gleich nochmal die Seite nochmal neu laden nach der nachdem die Sendung veröffentlicht wurde.
Preisgraf so.
Stornjoggen. Ja, dann äh würden wir uns natürlich freuen, wenn ihr äh zu uns stoßt.
Soweit der Werbeblock.
Ja, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir aber echt eine ganze Menge Leute vergrault.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist ja zumindest mal Anlass äh für äh gute Laune, weil jetzt kommen wir ja wieder zu unseren sonstigen Themen und die machen nicht ganz so gute Laune.
Das ist richtig. Günther Oettinger hat äh freudestrahlend gesagt, endlich das Ende von Roaming und Netzneutralität.
Super. Hätte man's auch nicht formulieren können. Beides vorbei. Damit sagte aber eigentlich relativ klar, worum's eigentlich die ganze Zeit ging.
Also der Oettinger ist wirklich, was haben wir anfangs noch gelacht, ne? Was haben wir gelacht?
Was haben wir gelacht damals? Das war noch witzig. Da konnten wir noch drüber lachen. Was ist geschehen? Ähm es gab ja eine,
ungefähr ein Jahr zurückliegende Positionierung des Europaparlamentes stark für eine,
regulatorische Festschreibung von Netzneutralität und.
Wir erinnern uns auch um äh Debatten mit der Vorgängerin von äh Herrn Öttinger, der Neli Cruise, die ja immer sagte, sie sei,
Für Netzneutralität aber,
Nur im Internet und nicht bei Spezialdiensten, das heißt, inhaltlich hat sie im Prinzip die gleiche,
Position vertreten, wie Öttinger, es war in Nuancen anders ähm,
die mir nicht bekannt sind, aber sie hat also sie hat im Prinzip die gleiche Position gehabt, aber sie hat das halt sie hat halt diese diese Nummer gezogen mit Büchernetzneutralität, was jetzt auch in dieser ähm.
In diesem Verordnungsentwurf der Fall ist. Aber sie hat äh sich dann nicht so hingestellt, wie Öttinger und gesagt, hier Taliban und äh haste nicht gesehen, ne? Öttinger hat ja dann,
nachgewiesenermaßen ähm irgendwie zu großen Prozentsatz nur Konzerne getroffen und Industrievertreter ähm in seinem Lobbyregister und sich mit den mit der Taliban äh der der Bürgerrechtler überhaupt nicht auseinandergesetzt,
und,
Nun gab es also von diesem über diese Position des Parlament, des Rates und der Kommission einen sogenannten Trilog,
Look ist ein Dialog mit drei Parteien. Ähm die haben,
Dieser Trilog hat drei Monate lang angedauert. Äh der Rat hat sich äh jeder Diskussion verweigert.
Und dann musste es plötzlich ganz schnell gehen, weil die lettische Ratspräsidentschaft äh jetzt endet.
Und da musste jetzt noch schnell ein politischer Erfolg her, damit man sagen kann, in dieser Ratspräsidentschaft wurde äh etwas äh erreicht. Und da wurde also jetzt eine,
Ein Verordnungsentwurf vorgestellt, den unsere Freunde von Edri, European Digital Rights, der,
Im Prinzip so gut wie einzigen ähm Bürgerrechten, Bürgerrechtlich, Netzpolitischen ähm Lobby-Organisationen vor Ort in Brüssel,
in, das ist allerdings falsch. Es gibt ja auch noch äh Access und ähm paar andere Organisationen, also Eddy ist nicht die einzige,
bekannteste auf jeden Fall und da kritisiert Joe McNamey diese Verordnung, das ist das Problem daran, ist mehrdeutig und unklar. Das heißt, sie wird jetzt noch mit den nachzufügenden Erwägungsgründen ergänzt werden.
Um überhaupt ihre um überhaupt zu erkennen, was denn da die rationale bei dieser Verordnung ist. Ähm es gibt keine klaren,
wirklich eine Entscheidung, dann müssen alle Mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen und dann geht das Ganze durch die Interpretation von Gericht und Aufsichtsbehörden, bis es dann irgendwann sich mal in nationalen Gesetzen eventuell wiederspiegelt.
Und bei sowas ist es natürlich schlecht, wenn man jetzt schon im im Verordnungsstadium sehr unklare Definitionen von allen möglichen Begriffen hat. So steht da zum Beispiel drin.
Äh Spezialdienste kann man einrichten, aber nur, wenn das notwendig ist. Und,
Nur wenn dafür eine ausreichende Netzkapazität zur Verfügung steht.
Also wir erinnern uns, diese ganzen sogenannten sind ja einer der Dreh- und Angelpunkte in der ganzen Diskussion um diese Netzneutralität gewesen. Weil das ja im Prinzip immer so dieses äh,
politische Sprachspiel war, dass von den äh Vertretern der Regierung primär äh immer so kolportiert wurde, na ja, wir wollen ja auch Netzneutralität, weil klingt ja toll äh
aber
es muss ja auch möglich sein, noch was anderes anzubieten, was nicht in diesem top Internet ist. Und das hat ja damit nichts zu tun und wir sind sicherlich in der Lage, bestimmte Kriterien äh aufzuzählen, wo sich das eben komplett entscheidet. Das hatten wir auch hier in den letzten äh Sendungen. Das war diese ganze sinnlose Debatte mit irgendwie äh ferngesteuerten Krankenwagen und allem
Quatsch, aber im Prinzip ist allein der Begriff Special Life Service quasi die Negierung von Netzneutralität, das,
Satz äh überhaupt zusammenzubauen äh ist quasi die Ablehnung von Netzneutralität. Und so wurde diese Debatte die ganze Zeit geführt, die Position des Parlaments.
Die ja äh unter anderem auch äh durch die politische,
Arbeit von äh Edri und in dem Zusammenhang müssen wir auch Thomas äh Lohninger nochmal erwähnen, vorangetrieben wurde. War ja das Parlament dahin zu bringen, eben genau äh solche Sachen abzulehnen,
wer da übrigens nochmal Interesse hat, sich das in der Gänze anzuhören, doch Netzpolitik hundertneunzehn, Netzneutralität extrem.
Da geht's 'ne Stunde eigentlich nur um darum.
Ich erinnere mich auch noch an eine Sendung, die wir auf den Dresdner Datensprung gemacht haben, wo wir uns das erste Mal mit dem Thema Netzneutralität äh beschäftigt haben. Denn es gibt einmal,
die äh technische,
Ebene, ne, wo man also, wo man dann sagt, okay, jedes Datenpaket muss gleich behandelt werden oder auch nicht. Äh das ist natürlich ähm,
nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen möglich, natürlich werden auch heute schon äh Videofeeds priorisiert gegenüber bestimmten anderen ähm Signalen, der entscheidende oder gegenüber bestimmter anderer Kommunikation,
Der entscheidende Punkt ist hier, dass daraus kein ähm zweiter Markt entstehen darf für die Provider. Also das, was verhindert werden soll, ist, dass jetzt irgendwie ähm,
mein Internetanbieter die Deutsche Telekom äh vielleicht bestimmte Anbieter, wie zum Beispiel Netflix,
versucht zu drosseln oder auszugrenzen und ihnen zu sagen, ja, wenn ihr an unsere Kunden heran wollt, dann müsst ihr mehr bezahlen, weil ihr nutzt äh,
ihr verdient Geld,
ähm was wo gegen sich eigentlich niemand ausspricht von diesem Bürgerrechtsorganisation, ist, dass die Deutsche Telekom dafür sorgt, dass natürlich,
Ein Video ähm.
Dafür gesorgt wird, dass jemand, der ein Video schauen will, äh da einen entsprechenden Fluss hat. Ja, und das nicht irgendwie untergeht in in einer Menge an Traffic, der vielleicht nicht äh so zeitkritisch ist, wie die wie ein Live-Video. Ähm,
Das Entscheidende ist, das muss dann eben so eine solche Bevorzugungsregel muss dann eben für alles Video gelten und nicht äh Ergebnis eines äh eines Deals sein,
wo man einen anderen Marktteilnehmer mehr oder weniger erpresst und mit ihm einen Deal
aushandelt, der wiederum zum Nachteil seiner Konkurrenten ist, ja? Das wäre dann wiederum die Möglichkeit für die ohnehin schon existierenden Monopole den Markteintritt für weitere ähm Marktteilnehmer halt vollständig zu
unmöglich zu machen. Also.
So und dann auf der Ebene sagen sie jetzt halt, ja, da gibt's ja Services, das ist eben dann nicht das Internet, ja. Ähm da da klammern sie also etwas aus, was äh sich eigentlich nicht ausklammern lässt.
Beziehungsweise sie versuchen jetzt eine Basis, eine gesetzliche Basis zu schaffen oder dieser dieser sogenannte Kompromiss lässt eben die Tür offen, definiert aber diesen Fall überhaupt nicht genau und.
Also genau, er definiert eine er definiert nicht, was ein Spezialdienst ist.
Oder unter welchen Bedingungen er überhaupt zustande äh kommen darf und das.
Doch, die Entschuldigung, die Bedingung, äh ich habe gerade ein bisschen zu weit ausgeholt. Die Bedingungen sind schon klar. Wenn es keine negativen Auswirkungen auf das normal Internet hat.
Und äh wenn es notwendig ist,
ja? Was, wo man prinzipiell ja, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, wunderbar ist verboten worden. Ja, weil du kannst ja nicht, also diese diese Debatte, diese Argumentation drehen sich ja auch so schön im Kreis, dass sie immer sagen, so,
Wenn wir Netzzentralität, dann geht hier gar nix mehr. Wir müssen bei Verstopfung müssen wir ähm,
Müssen wir in den Traffic eingreifen. Ja, stimmt, muss man machen. Wird auch gemacht. Hat auch nie jemand wirklich irgendwie gegen sich gegen gegen positioniert. Ähm aber dann sagen sie,
Ja und wir müssen auch äh äh Spezialdienste machen.
Und weil weil das Internet ja so äh überfrachtet ist. Also es ist halt totaler, es ist einfach unsinnig. Es geht halt also ne, entweder du hast da hast die Kapazität,
dann brauchst du aber auch nicht in den Traffic einzugreifen. Oder du hast sie nicht,
und dann tust du es, aber dann kannst du wiederum nach dieser Regulation eigentlich keine Special Services anbieten, weil sie sich eben zum Nachteil des normalen Internets äh äh begeben. Das heißt, wir haben hier eine, also
ein inhirent,
unsinniges Dokument, dessen Auslegungen eben jetzt in alle Richtungen eigentlich noch möglich ist und das natürlich immer ähm gefährlich. Gleichzeitig verpflichten sie aber dann die Anbieter zu ausführlicher Auskunft über die Auswirkungen, obwohl sie ja sagen, dass es
Keine Auswirkungen geben darf, sonst dürfen sie das nicht machen. Also es.
Ja?
Dann ist der insgesamt der Geltungsbereich dieser Verordnung nicht klar definiert dieses Urteil schreibe ich von Juristen ab und sagen dass also Sperren und Filtern zulässig ist und aber keine,
definieren, geben keine klare Definition, was Sperren und Filter sein können,
und vor allem nicht, welche rechtlichen Pflichten damit einhergehen. Wir haben ja in ähm UK zum Beispiel diese,
Diese Pornofilter, die irgendwie so vor sich hingepflegt werden, die auch äh tatsächlich über die Provider nicht
ähm gleich sind, wo es dann diese Seite äh ayurvean blockt oder so was gibt, wo man dann jede einzelne Seite sehen kann, dann wird gezeigt, aha, in dem Netz geblockt, in dem nicht und so
da eben kein vernünftiger, rechtlicher Rahmen äh geschaffen. Und da muss ich jetzt,
unabhängig von meiner Position zur Netzneutralität sagen, dass das natürlich grundsätzlich handwerklich scheiße ist, wenn du eine Verordnung zur Vereinheitlichung deines Binnenmarktes haben möchtest,
In der, aus der nicht klar hervorgeht, was die soll, ja, in der die Begriffe nicht vernünftig definiert sind, damit erreichst sie ja auch das Ziel nicht, was du, welches auch immer du erreichen möchtest, ja, sei es irgendwie die Abschaffung von Netzneutralität und ähm,
und Roaming und und Internet oder so, ja, wenn du die Begriffe nicht klar definierst, ähm dann hast du eben.
Mangelhafte Harmonisierung.
Mangelhafte Harmonisierung des Binnenmarktes und das kann ja wohl keiner wollen.
Jetzt wollen sie, aber jetzt kommen wir mal zu dem zu dem Schönen. Da habe ich jetzt, war ich ja auch interessiert. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass,
EU-Roaming so billig ist, in einem Zwischenschritt sollen jetzt die Roaming-Aufschläge am dreißigsten April zweitausendsechzehn sinken.
Dann dürfen Telefonate im EU-Ausland nur noch fünf Cent pro Minute kosten. Aber es ist, glaube ich, fünf Cent mehr,
für mich würden sie dann billiger als kann ich besser ins Ausland fahren um nach Deutschland zu telefonieren?
Also das sind die, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, eben die Aufschläge. Ähm derzeit ist das neunzehn Cent für abgehend fünf Cent für eingehende Anrufe,
Obergrenze für SMS zwei Cent, derzeit sechs Cent und beim Surfen darf jedes Megabite ein Daten maximal,
fünf Cent, also ein Fuffi für ein Gigabyte,
Kosten, das ist derzeit zwanzig Cent, das wären also dann zweihundert Euro pro Gigabyte, ne? Ähm,
Vollständig müssen sollen diese Roaminggebühren am fünfzehnten Juni zweitausendsiebzehn auslaufen. Das heißt, dann gibt es KI innerhalb der EU keine Roaminggebühren mehr. So.
Denkst du, ah okay, in Ordnung, das hat, das hat der Linus jetzt schön abgelesen, das klingt vernünftig, das scheint ordentlich definiert zu sein, keine Räuminggebühren mehr ab fünfzehnter Juni zweitausendsiebzehn in der EU.
Es sei denn, der Nutzer telefoniert häufiger im EU-Ausland.
Häufiger? Ja. Aha.
Ja. Und nicht und nicht nur bei gelegentlichen Reisen. Und zu zu dem.
Wir machen das, wir machen das sozusagen kostenlos.
Es sei denn, du nutzt das.
SS-Seite, man man nimmt es auch wirklich in Anspruch. Ja. Ja.
Mit anderen Worten, da ist wieder so ein so ein vollständiges Loophall drin, ja, sodass sie halt jetzt sowas machen werden wie ja, du hast.
Kostenlos für die ersten zehn Minuten und danach, sorry. Ja. Ist leider zu teuer.
Zehn Minuten reicht ja wohl.
Und zudem sollen die Anbieter entstandene höhere Kosten abrechnen können. Ja mit wem? Ja, kannst du dir vorstellen. Also ist so total ähm totaler Quatsch, ne.
Ja, vor allem also mit sozusagen das Ausrufen des Endes von Netzneutralität und Roming ist sozusagen das Ende von Netzneutralität, aber Rumhängen gibt's trotzdem noch. Super.
Ja, aber also ne, sehr ähm blurrys,
ähm nennt der äh schwammig und,
ähm widersprüchlich ambivalent nennt,
diese Verordnung. Wir werden jetzt halt sehen, wir müssen halt noch ein bisschen auf diese Erwägungsgründe warten und sehen, wie sie dann äh ausgelegt wird, aber wenn wir, ich meine, wenn Öttinger im Spiel ist, ne, dann äh,
verheißt das in der Regel nichts Gutes und das sieht äh das sieht äh sehr schlecht aus. Also die das man kann ja.
Muss man auch sagen, das ist jetzt auch noch nicht das letzte Wort, sondern das ist jetzt sozusagen.
Genau muss noch von den Mitgliedsstaaten ratifiziert werden. Äh nur noch? Ja. Also es kommen jetzt die Erwägungsgründe hinzu.
Müssen jetzt erstmal vorgelegt werden.
Genau. Und dann geht das gesamte Paket, da müssen die Mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen.
Das heißt, dass jetzt sozusagen diese Ausarbeitung keiner weiteren äh keines weiteren Trilogs bedarf.
Das ist jetzt das Ende des Trilogs, ja.
Was mich ein bisschen wundert, ist, warum sich das Parlament an der Stelle nicht durch hat, durchsetzen können.
Tja.
Mit so einer relativ klaren äh Aufgabenstellung.
Tja, das weiß ich nicht. Wurden vielleicht auch einfach weich gekocht.
Ich meine, also wie halt, also es wird halt bemängelt, der Rat hat halt einfach jede Diskussion verweigert und ist dann auf einmal,
mit der mit der mit der Tür ins Haus gekommen. So ist es halt, ne? Ich meine, das Parlament hat ja äh,
Unter Umständen da auch, ne, nur weil das Parlament mal Mehrheit für etwas hatte
heißt es ja nicht, dass das Parlament hier zu Feuer und Flamme hinter dieser ganzen Sache steht und bereit ist, sich da irgendwie einen Marathon äh Trilo Trilogien,
fertig machen zu lassen, ne?
Ciao,
Dann äh atmen wir ein äh wenig durch und schauen, was die anderen äh Mehrheitsinhaber so an Sonderregelungen durchgesetzt bekommen,
Hier geht es, wenn man sich schon denken kann, um den NSA oder auch Geheimdienst, Untersuchungsausschuss, wie heißen der jetzt eigentlich offiziell?
Ach, das war doch so ein ganz langer Titel. Den hatte an, den hatten wir auch schon mal, haben wir schon mehrmals gegoogelt, machen wir nochmal. Ähm der,
Untersuchungsausschuss, quasi steht noch nicht mal.
Das ist der erste Untersuchungsausschuss. So war das nämlich, genau. Das ist der erste Untersuchungsausschuss.
Und der wirkliche Titel.
Gute Frage.
Erster Untersuchungsausschuss, so.
Zur Untersuchung der der hat so einen ganz langen den hatten wir auch schon mal hier verlesen. Ich finde das Tim, ich habe dir ja schon mal gesagt.
Entschuldigung, ich dachte.
Keine Fragen, die ich nicht beantworten kann.
Was weiß ich, was du nicht beantworten kannst.
Sei froh, dass ich meine persönlichen Probleme noch außen vor lasse.
Also ähm auf der in der Pressemitteilung des Deutschen Bundestages wird er auch NSA-Ausschuss genannt, ja. Ähm.
Zumindest ist er so, in der Wikipedia aufgeführt, also äh belassen wir das jetzt auch einfach bei diesem Begriff.
Nö, jetzt suchen wir das raus. Wir, das steht ja wohl in der Wikipedia hoffentlich drin. Die wird ja oder ist das wird ja wohl für irgendwas noch.
Ich habe nur gesagt in der Wikipedia ist er auch so genannt. Und man äh wirft sich ja bei einer Wikipedia immer auf das Dominieren, auf den dominierenden Begriff, wie es gemeinhin genannt wird.
Aber da wird doch auch stehen, ähm wie der, wie der offizielle Titel ist.
Ich will jetzt aber keine zwanzig Seiten äh Wikipedia durchlesen, während wir hier eine Sendung aufnehmen.
Dann stelle solche Fragen nicht.
Ja, ich bin ja nun auch schon ruhig. Auf jeden Fall gab's ja die äh Debatte um diesen Sonderermittler.
Wir erinnern uns, in der ganzen Fragestellung um Einsicht in geheime Dokumente, wo die Bundesregierung äh meint, na ja wir würden euch da ja gerne reingucken lassen, aber ist ja geheim.
Gab's.
Selektoren, nicht um irgendwelche Dokumente, sondern spezifisch um die Selektoren.
Ja, aber letztlich ist ja diese geheim,
Haltungsfragestellung steht ja hier im Raum. Und das ist ja im Prinzip auch etwas, was über die Sedikturen hinausgeht, weil was was ist, werden in Zukunft andere Dokumente, die denselben Klassifizierungsgrad haben, auch äh in Frage stellen. Also hier,
darüber debattiert, wie grundsätzlich eigentlich,
sehr Geheimes aufgeklärt werden kann, was halt geheim bleiben muss, weil sonst äh irgendjemand den Pöter versohlt bekommt
und da gab's dann halt diese neue Idee des Sonderermittlers, der eben zwischen dem Untersuchungsausschuss
und den Beteiligten Behörden, in dem Fall halt Kanzleramt, beziehungsweise eben den Geheimdiensten steht und der eben temporär dieses Einsichtsrecht äh erhält, um dann wiederum den Untersuchungsausschuss zu berichten, sprich nochmal so ein Proxi
zwischen diesen beiden Entitäten was an sich halt auch schon mal ein rechtlicher Streitapfel sein könnte.
Er soll vor allem, er soll er soll halt also er dieser Sonderermittler bekommt dann Einsicht in diese in diesem Fall in dieses Selektorenlisten, kann da reinschauen,
darf dann dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss Bericht erstatten.
Darin aber nichts Geheimes verraten, was er eingesehen hat.
Ja
Das heißt, das ist so dieses, ne.
Und.
Nicht drüber reden dürfen so. Also da wird halt so der wird dann da am Ende sitzen, genauso wie alle ähm BND Mitarbeiter vor ihm,
ja? Und wenn dann irgendwie äh wenn dann eine Frage kommt, wenn dann der Herr sagt, ja äh haben die denn zum Beispiel gegen sie Mensch spioniert? Dann wird der halt zu seinem,
gucken und der wird sagen, darüber gibt's keine Auskunft.
Ist geheim. Ist geheim. Ja.
Also es ist wirklich ein, ich meine, das ist wirklich ein ein Witz wie da die die Untersuchungen und Aufklärung verhindert wird. Ähm von Seiten,
das äh Bundeskanzleramt.
Und der großen Koalition.
Und der großen Koalition. Die Opposition besteht entsprechend auch darauf, dass die Liste
Selektoren von den Abgeordneten selbst eingesehen werden kann und wird auch angekündigt darauf noch äh in diesem Sommer vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht zu klagen, weil sie das eben als eine Behinderung der ähm.
Breites Parlaments an.
Freiheit des Parlaments ansieht, ja? Der der Untersuchungsausschuss ist ja auch ein eine ähm.
Institution in dem Fall der der legislative gegenüber der Exekutive und diese eben in dieser Form einzuschränken äh halten sie eben finde ich äh akzeptabel.
Die Regierung wiederum argumentiert, äh sie wolle so einen Bruch des Völkerrechts verhindern. Ja, also wenn jetzt quasi äh,
Mein Völkerrecht ist ja sowieso ganz witzig, ne? Das gibt's ja im Prinzip gar nicht. Ähm solange sich keiner dran hält und ähm das,
tun ja die wenigsten, ähm aber das jetzt irgendwie zu einem zu einem Völkerrechtsbruch hoch zu stilisieren, wenn äh ein ein Untersuchungsausschuss äh Einsicht verlangt in die Spionage, die eigene,
Spionageorgane im,
Im Namen fremder Mächte, ja, im eigenen Land getätigt haben. Darin dann wiederum daraus wiederum ein Völkerrechtsbruch zu konstruieren. Das ist schon ähm
gut und da sieht man auch, warum man Jura so lange studieren muss. Ja, da musste sicherlich ähm einige ähm Kniffe anwenden, um um so was ernsthaft ähm.
Belegen zu können und das irgendwie durch einen Lachttest durchzukriegen. Aber das gelingt ihnen hier offensichtlich.
Was ich aber eigentlich meinen mit Völkerrecht ist ja jetzt hier nicht irgendwie die äh,
Charter der Vereinten Nationen oder äh so etwas, sondern hier geht's halt eher um interstaatliche Verträge. Und ähm sozusagen so supranationale Regelungen und damit eben dann auch,
Wiederum Geheimverträge zwischen Staaten,
Davon ist ja hier im Wesentlichen die Rede, oder? Also, ja, wir haben da was Geheimes, von dem auch unsere Bürger nichts wissen, weil ist ja geheim. Und äh wir dürfen das ja nicht verletzen, weil da stehen Gründe drin, die wollte ich euch leider auch nicht sagen können, weil die sind auch geheim.
Und so dreht sich das halt äh
im Kreis. Und das äh dürfte eine der interessantesten äh Entscheidungen des Bundesverfassungsgerichts werden so in der Zukunft, weil das natürlich wirklich eine interessante Frage ist. Inwiefern
hier nicht am Ende, jetzt komme ich wieder mit meinem Grund positiven Ansatz, ja? Sozusagen auch der Status solcher,
supranationalen Verträge äh in Frage gestellt wird. Ja, also sind die zum Beispiel überhaupt zulässig?
Darf man überhaupt geheime Vereinbarungen äh auf dieser Ebene äh führen,
und das fände ich ja durchaus mal zu begrüßen, dass so etwas beleuchtet wird. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass sich das Verfassungsgericht bei so einer Antwort,
zumindest Zeit nimmt.
Ja, also da da spielen natürlich jetzt also
Spiel natürlich dann noch andere Sachen rein, ne? Ähm wir erinnern uns an die äh Folge mit Katharina über
TTIP, wo es ja wohl ja auch im Prinzip die Idee im Raume steht, einen, dass,
starten, Verträge machen, die einfach nationales Recht im Prinzip dann wiederum bestimmen. Ähm.
Ich finde es trotzdem witzig, da irgendwie so Völkerrecht, Völkerrecht, ich bitte dich, also es ist einfach, ne?
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Die News ist aber, dass es jetzt jemanden gibt, der äh der der diese Sonderermittlerrolle bekommen soll.
Und da haben sich Union und SPD darauf einigen können, dass es.
Nein, nein, du musst sagen, eine breite Mehrheit.
Eine eine überwältigende Mehrheit, ja, hat sich äh darauf einigen können, ja, CDU und SPD gegen die ja hier ermittelt wird, haben sich also einigen können.
Müssen sich auch schützen.
Ja, die haben sich jetzt, die müssen, ja, die haben gesagt, okay und der Name, der da jetzt äh zur Debatte steht,
Ist der Herr graulich.
Der war äh einundvierzig Jahre im öffentlichen Dienst als Jurist tätig, fünfzehn Jahre am Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Ich glaube, in Leipzig, SPD-Mitglied, ähm,
und auch sonst ein ein schätzenswertes äh Mitglied der Gesellschaft und das hat sich der scheint also jetzt da ähm.
Rolle zu bekommen. Er hat ähm in seiner Forschung oder in seiner,
Ne, also Juristen schreiben ja dann auch mal, der hat publiziert zu Nachrichtendienst, Polizei und Telekommunikationsrecht. Ähm also es scheint schon jemand zu sein, der äh in dem Bereich,
Wahrscheinlich hoffentlich kompetent ist. Es geht aber hier auch eben nicht darum, die Personalie zu kritisieren, sondern eben diesen, diesen grundsätzlichen Rahmen
dass äh der Untersuchungsausschuss hier sehr stark an seiner an seiner Arbeit gehindert wird, denn.
Wie heißt der nochmal? Entschuldigung. Ja.
Gräulich mit A U.
Ja, mit A oder L.
Er sein. Ich habe, ich muss jetzt hier kurz wieder durch scrollen. Tim, ich habe dir das doch gesagt mit den Fragen, die ich nicht beantworten kann. Also.
Na ja gut, also ich hätte ja auch selber mal gucken können.
Also mit graulich, Kurtraulich, Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt gräulich gesagt, ähm gut graulich.
Ja. Gut. Mhm. Richtig so.
Aber ne, wie gesagt, nix gegen Herrn Graulich, aber das ist halt insgesamt ein ein Problem.
Der äh,
der des Verhältnisses zwischen eben Exekutive und Legislative und die Legislative nimmt ja hier ähm eine kontrollierende,
Funktion gegenüber der Exekutive ein indem sie ein Untersuchungsausschuss einberaubt, in dem denke ich die Hauptbeschuldigten, die Exekutive sind,
ist oder in der Exekutive sitzen und da ist es natürlich schon interessant, wenn wenn dann da irgendwie jemand gestellt wird, der von mir aus honorig ist, aber der ähm,
eben über seine Erkenntnisse dann auch nicht wird sprechen dürfen. Das ist natürlich schon sehr.
Lächerlich. Insofern sehr sehr interessant, was wir da wieder für eine schöne äh einen schönen Punkt gefunden haben, wo man sich jetzt monatelang drüber streiten können wird ohne voranzukommen. Das äh.
Sicherlich im Interesse von CDU und SPD.
Ja dann gibt's da noch was nachzulegen, ne? Aber zum.
Cyber, ja, das war jetzt irgendwie ein eigentlich nur eine Kurzmeldung. Mal gucken, wie lange wir drüber reden. Der im Bundestag gibt's jetzt Netzsperren. Ähm.
Nicht nur Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, ähm und zwar sollen diese Netzsperren verhindern, dass sich weitere Rechner in Netz mit Schadsoftware wie Trojanern infizieren. Ähm und da gibt's also eine.
Vom BSI-Quarantäneliste genannte Liste, auf der mehrere zehntausend Einträge sind. Ähm.
Wo gesagt wird, okay, darauf lasst den Zugriff darauf lassen wir jetzt mal nicht. Äh nicht zu.
Und wollen dadurch die Leute eben die die Parlamentarier davor schützen, sich mit Trojanern äh anzustecken. Äh zu infizieren. Jetzt wissen wir natürlich.
Bisher ist ja der der Akt aktuelle Stand, dass der Trojaner, unter dem das Parlament gerade leidet.
Per E-Mail zugestellt worden sei, insofern äh ist jetzt die Frage, inwiefern,
eine eine Webseitensperre, dass jetzt wirklich nochmal äh da eine adäquate Reaktion drauf ist
aber es wird ja gesagt, diese Webseite ist im Zusammenhang mit der Verbreitung von Chartsoftware aufgefallen, daher wurde aus Sicherheitsgründen der Zugriff auf diese Webseite automatisch blockiert. Dies geschieht zum Schutz ihres Arbeitsplatz-PCs
und des Regierungsnetzes vor Schadsoftware. Ist, ist eigentlich der Bundestag Regierung? Nee, ne?
Müsste man dann nochmal einen Backreport schicken. Bei Rückfragen wird diese automatisiert erstellte auf diese automatisiert erstellte Benachrichtigung wenden sie sich bitte zeitnah unter Angabe der Webseite sowie Referenznummer haste nicht gesehen,
über ihren IT-Sicherheitsbeauftragten an das Computer-Emergency response Team für Bundesbehörden,
Bund, im Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik BSI.
So, jetzt ist natürlich so die Sache. Natürlich ist grundsätzlich ne, wenn man sagt, man muss eine große.
Infrastruktur mit vielen Windows-Rechnern und vielen äh sagen wir mal durchschnittlich oder,
begabten Nutzern oder durchschnittlich aufgeklärten Nutzern im im Bereich dieses Risikofeldes verantworten. Und man weiß von bestimmten, von bestimmten Domains äh gibt's halt ordentlich äh,
Myware.
Oder bestimmte IP-Adressen oder Domains sind bekannt dafür als Command an Control Server zu dienen, dann können natürlich solche Sperren durchaus ein.
Eine adäquate Maßnahme sein, um äh Infektionen zu verhindern oder deren äh Ausmaß einzuschränken.
Sinnvoller, denke ich, aber ist es, einfach zu schauen, ob sich da jemand hin verbindet,
ja? Weil das dir im Zweifelsfall kannst du dann einfach den,
Die Nutzer können trotzdem noch auf allen möglichen Mist zugreifen und wenn jemand sich auf eine dieser Listen eine dieser Seiten verbindet, dann gehst du halt hin und kontrollierst, ne? Und guckst, hat sich da irgendwie
haben wir Anzeichner einer Infektion bei diesem System oder sonst was. Ähm der Vorteil, wenn du sagst, du statt,
zu verbieten Monitors zu, das haben ja auch viele Diktatoren schon gelernt, ne? Nicht zensieren.
Sondern Daten gewinnen. Mhm.
Sondern überwachen ist besser. Ähm der Vorteil, den du äh den du hast, ist,
Dass deine Nutzer nicht anfangen, deine Sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu unterwandern. Ähm was nämlich jetzt passieren wird, ist, dass natürlich die äh die Nutzer,
Umso mehr von diesen Palakom-Geräten ähm weggedrängt werden, wenn diese Sperren nämlich übersperren. Und bei irgendwie mehreren zehn bis hunderttausend Seiten kann das sehr gut sein,
dass sie halt irgendwann, dass sie da halt in dem Bereich des Overblockings bekommen.
Gleichzeitig kannst du natürlich das Underblocking nie aus äh schließen, das heißt, du blockierst wahrscheinlich zu viel und einiges Wichtige nicht.
Deswegen ist diese Sperrerei ja,
eine eine schwierige Sache, aber ich könnte jetzt auch nicht behaupten, dass sich das nicht eventuell auch versuchen, mal machen würde, wenn ich gerade irgendwie äh die Hütte am Brennen hätte wegen äh Trojaner.
Ist sicherlich eine Ausnahmesituation, auf der anderen Seite auch ein schöner
äh kleiner Testballon, wo dann die Bundestagsabgeordneten mal so sehen können, wie so äh die von ihnen beschlossenen Maßnahmen so allgemein eigentlich so wirken. Ist ja sowieso sehr interessant. Mich würde übrigens auch mal interessieren, jetzt wo der Bundestag schon seit ein paar Jahren Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat,
wie groß eigentlich die Aufklärungsquote äh ist. Also wie viele Kinder.
Ja, bei dem Medat hier nicht so eine Reaktion auf die Sache, haben sie vor Ort seinen Speicherung ja erstmal gekürzt. Das ist eigentlich der Oberhammer, ne? Wir rennen da draußen jetzt so, ja, längere Vorratsdaten sprechen, hier, ne und.
Wir müssen ja Kinderschänder.
Kinderschänder, Kinderchen und dann auf einmal so Scheiße, damit das immer schön kürzen. Ja, ja, okay, aber das ähm.
Na ja, aber auch die organisierte Kriminalität äh äh muss ja bekämpft werden. Drogenhandel, äh Krux ist ja schon gefunden worden auf dem Bundestagsklo, also von daher ähm warte ich ehrlich gesagt auf die Ergebnisse und bisher scheint da noch nicht so viel passiert zu sein.
Da müssen vielleicht einfach mal die Zügel ein bisschen angezogen werden.
Neben der, neben der technischen Komponente, gibt's hier noch einen anderen Aspekt, denn ich habe ja gesagt, das BSI, habe ich ja gerade verlesen, stellt diese Listen und das BSI ist ja auch als Ansprechpartner genannt und es gab ja eigentlich immer diese strenge,
Weigerungen des Parlamentes, das BSI irgendwie bei sich äh,
aktiv werden zu lassen, weil das BSI ja dem.
Untersteht.
Genau. Dem BMI untersteht. Und ähm,
Deswegen möchte das, möchten die Parlamentarier das das BSI nicht so gerne in der Hütte haben und so sagt dann auch der Lars Klingbeil, Netzpolitischer Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion äh geschundene Seele. Ähm,
Es ist mit dem freien Mandat unvereinbar, dass eine Regierungsbehörde entscheidet, auf welche Informationen Abgeordnete zugreifen können und diese Kommunikation zudem protokolliert.
Hat ein Punkt.
Absolut. Schön, dass die SPD solche Statements macht. Leider.
Ja. Ist mit meiner Freiheit auch unvereinbar, dass die äh aber lassen wir das. Ich meine, die SPD, was soll das?
In Paris war äh war er äh ordentlich, wie nennt man das? Progo.
Standard würde ich sagen.
Ganz nichts Neues aus Paris.
In Paris fliegen halt immer die Fetzen und die Steine auch und ähm ja. Das so ist.
Willst du noch was dazu erzählen oder?
Ja, also es wurde mal wieder kräftig demonstriert zwar in diesem Fall gegen Uber,
Äh wir hatten das Thema hier auch schon vor äh einigen Sendungen hast du das mal angebracht mit der ganzen Problematik rund um die Schering äh Economy
und ähm ja, jetzt äh wurde halt fleißig äh demonstriert und äh,
wer sich da so aufregt, sind vor allem Taxifahrer, die halt durch das ähm,
Virale Geschäftsmodell von Uber, vielleicht ist das nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, überhaupt nicht das Geschäftsmodell von Uber in ihrer Existenz
bedroht sehen, die äh Demonstrationen gegenüber, die ja mal in London, glaube ich, angefangen hatten,
aus den USA ist mir übrigens nichts dergleichen bekannt, aber in Europa sieht das halt ein bisschen anders aus, weil wir hier einfach ein anderes
Beschäftigungsmodell auch äh haben üblicherweise für den öffentlichen Transport und damit eben auch für Taxis. Das hat ja leider dem Dienst dann auch eher noch extra Aufmerksamkeit äh beschert und da sind dann, glaube ich, dann auch gleich die Überzahlen um
was weiß ich, wie viele hundert Prozent nach oben gegangen. Ja, Uber ist halt eine Firma, die.
Mit verschiedensten Nationen weltweit, im Clinch liegt, ob der jeweiligen lokalen Gesetzgebung, dazu gehört natürlich auch Deutschland und der erste Versuch hier in Deutschland,
überhaupt Fuß zu fassen mit dem sogenannten Dienst. Der ist ja mittlerweile verboten worden,
war halt so der Versuch mit normalen,
Autos und ganz normalen Fahrern, Menschen, die jetzt keinerlei besondere Ausweise äh haben, so wie einen persönlichen Beförderungsschein oder einen regelmäßigen Sittes oder sowas. Ähm,
da halt einfach mal so anzubieten
Ne, so wie halt Airbnb. Ich habe hier ein Zimmer frei. Wohn doch mal. Äh ich habe hier einen Sitz frei, fahre doch einfach mal mit. So. Und dann ist sie eigentlich durchgekommen, weil äh eben genau diese Bedingungen, die Personenbeförderungsschein et cetera einfach als vor
gegeben, ähm festgestellt wurde vom Gericht, denn äh,
Mitfahrgelegenheit, wie sie das wohl auch teilweise versucht haben, zu definieren, ging das halt nicht durch, weil ja in dem Moment nicht äh die Fahrt ohnehin irgendwo hingeht, wo dann jemand entscheidet, sich da zuzusetzen, sondern es ist ja hier in Anführungsstrichen der Kunde, der
die Ansage macht und dementsprechend kommen sie damit nicht durch.
Müssen wir noch dazu sagen, das Taxigewerbe ist ja noch ein bisschen weiter reguliert, als nur, dass man Personen Beförderungsschein braucht, ne, also Taxige,
Taxi ist wirklich mit Lizenz und Ortskundigkeitsprüfung, ne, die müssen also der Taxifahrer muss tatsächlich in der Lage sein
dir die schnellste und billigste Route äh zu fahren und ähm die haben natürlich dann auch gewisse Auflagen, was ihre Preise angeht. Können die Preise nicht frei bestimmen,
sind äh verpflichtet dich zu befördern und wenn du auch nur irgendwie um die Ecke fahren möchtest und so. Und all das sind äh,
Regulationen, die den Taxi fahren aufs Auge gedrückt werden, die natürlich auch das Betreiben eines Taxiunternehmens oder eines äh selbstständigen Taxis ähm,
durchaus mit mit Aufwendungen versehen, die eben diese ganzen über ähm Pop-Leute nicht haben, ja.
Genau und wahrscheinlich auch nicht die UB X äh Leute, das ist ja der andere Dienst. Mit dem Uber ist jetzt in Deutschland äh probiert. Das ist so quasi die etwas ähm,
ähm abgemilderte Variante von diesem Popdienst. Da haben dann die Autos irgendwie eine Mietwagenzulassung, wie auch immer sie bekommen, sind aber nicht wirklich eben äh Taxis und die Fahrer müssen aber einen Personenbeförderungsschein haben,
Allerdings kommen halt so andere Sachen wie regelmäßiger Sehtest et cetera äh nicht dazu und das ist dann sozusagen die Leselinie der Auseinandersetzung.
Ich vermute, dass das äh dass das in Ordnung sein wird, weil diese Mietwagen gibt es ja in äh Deutschland auch. Also es gibt Taxis und Mietwagen und Mietwagen,
sind, unterscheiden sich im Prinzip dadurch, dass sie keine Taxisschilder aufm Dach haben und auch keine äh Laufkundschaft sich abholen dürfen. Also du kannst als ähm als du kannst als Mietwagen,
am Taxistand stehen, du darfst nicht Leute von der Straße einsammeln, ähm aber du darfst,
Du darfst eine vermittelte Fahrt annehmen. Also wenn du bei der Taxizentrale anrufst, dann können die dir einen Mietwagen schicken, dann müssen sie nicht, müssen sie nicht unbedingt ein Taxi für nehmen. Ähm und diesen, das will äh Uber jetzt machen mit Uber X,
und das halte ich für etwas solidere ähm Idee.
Prinzip so ein Chauffeursmodell, ne. So.
Nennt sich halt Mietfangen, also heißt auch tatsächlich in Deutschland so. Mietwagen mit mit Fahrer.
Ja klar, also halt Chauffeur eben jemand, der dich fährt und das Auto auch gleich äh mitbringt und muss auch sagen, da habe ich jetzt auch so erstmal nichts gegen,
einzuwenden. Also ich meine, Uber hat ja so eine ganze Bandbreite von ähnlichen Chauffeursdiensten
Ähm also klassisch ist ja sozusagen dieses Uber Black. Damit haben die, glaube ich, auch mal angefangen, nicht? Das war dann halt relativ äh ausladende Limousinen, also teurere Autos, wo man eben gerne vorfährt,
ein bisschen Eindruck zu schinden, damit haben sie im Prinzip angefangen und die haben das auch nochmal ausgebaut mit so einem Luxusauto
Variante, da kannst du halt nochmal extra viel bezahlen, wenn du eben jetzt auch noch irgendwie
dicke Hose mit deinem Sportgerät machen willst, dann gibt's das Ganze auch noch als SUV, also ist irgendwie alles da. Ähm ja, muss man sehen. Aber,
Auf jeden Fall gibt's halt hier nachhaltige Auseinandersetzungen und interessant ist, dass ihr dann sogar den Chef äh äh festgenommen haben von in Frankreich,
Also in Polizeigewahrsam, was auch immer, also festgenommen, ist wahrscheinlich nicht die richtige Formulierung. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie ihn zu seinem eigenen Schutz,
festgehalten haben oder nicht, ne?
Zwei Entwicklungen trennen. Also es gab einmal relativ krasse Proteste der Taxifahrer in Paris. Die haben dann irgendwie sowas gemacht wie alle auf die Autobahn gefahren und irgendwie langsam gefahren und so und dann haben den Verkehr zum Stillstand gebracht
und dann gab's auch noch irgendwie so eine sehr schräge Story, wo Courtney Love,
mit einem Uber auf dem Weg zum Flughafen gewesen und ist in diese äh Proteste gekommen,
Und die Taxifahrer, die waren halt grade so richtig schön warm, ja und,
haben dann den den Uber Pop, das ist nämlich in wird in Frankreich noch oder ist in in Paris wohl noch möglich. Ähm und haben diese äh haben dieses.
Dieses Fahrzeug dann angegriffen, ja? Also unter anderem wurden zwei Oberpoptos in Brand gesetzt. Es gibt irgendwie ein schönes Foto, wo das ein Auto auf dem Kopf liegt, ja. Ähm.
Und das Auto von von Courtney Love, die schreibt also irgendwie so äh.
Er hat also irgendwie Fotos aus diesem Uber Pop-Auto gemacht. Äh the First Corus de Stroyd all yeah slash beat with bads, also mit Schlägern drauf,
Und sie fühlt sich halt irgendwie wie in der äh wie in Bagdad oder sie wäre lieber in Bagdad, weil sie sich da sicherer fühlen würde.
In Frankreich gibt's halt eine relativ ähm sage ich mal, ausgeprägte Tradition von äh Protest und Streik.
Auch schon seit der Französischen Revolution war ja auch nicht irgendwie von Mahatma Gandhi angeführt und die sehen sich dann immer mal wieder,
auch in dieser Tradition, vor allem, wenn prekäre ähm Anstellungsverhältnisse angegriffen werden, äh wie hier die Taxifahrer von,
von der Uber Konkurrenz. Aber das hat natürlich schon echt Ausmaße, ne, dass die, ich meine, die das ist schon übel.
Und auf der anderen Seite wird eben gegenüber ermittelt wegen illegaler Beschäftigung und widerrechtlicher Verarbeitung von personenbezogenen Daten,
Und in diesem Rahmen wurden jetzt irgendwie zwei hochrangige Manager, einmal der der ähm Frankreich-Chef und einmal der Europachef dann auch von der Polizei mal irgendwie äh,
in Gewahrsam oder zum Gespräch gebeten, weil sie doch äh bei den seit Oktober laufenden Ermittlungen ähm.
Unterstützen sollten mit ihrer Aussage als,
oder Beschuldigter oder Zeuge, sie wollen auch noch Daten dort beschlagnahmen. Das wird sicherlich nicht ganz so einfach. Ähm und der französische Innenminister Bernar.
Der hat das Unternehmen schon als illegal und arrogant bezeichnet und die Pariser Polizei dann am Donnerstag angewiesen, Uber Pop äh in der Hauptstadt doch mal bitte zu untersagen.
Politischer Aspekt noch nicht so hundertprozentig äh klar geworden, aber.
Das ist, das ist, Alter.
Wasn?
Das ist das ist die das äh du wirst irgendwann sehen, ja, dass das dass das sehr äh ähm net sich ist,
da da kommt so Netz und ähm Globalisierung und äh Deregulierung und äh Präkariat, das hat alles, das ist so ein richtiger,
Das ist so ein richtiger Thriller. Das sind das sind da an diesen Konflikten ja, werden gerade wirklich zentrale Herausforderungen für unsere Gesellschaft in den nächsten Jahren und Jahrzehnten ausgetragen.
Tja, da hoffe ich mal, dass die U-Bahnfahrer da nicht äh in der Tradition der ist äh behandelt werden. Ja, also,
weiß ja, wie's da abgeht in der französischen äh äh Nationalhymne, ja, da wird also geschlachtet und geschlitzt.
Das Blut, das spritzt.
Du, das ist äh der französische Revolution. Wie gesagt, war nichts für Kinder. Nein, ähm um es, also es ist, es ist halt schon,
Ich finde das immer wieder spannend eben, ne, dass sage ich mal diese alten tradierten,
Geschäftsmodelle, die werden halt jetzt von diesen Silicon Valley Arschlochkapitalisten so richtig bösartig angegriffen, ne? Also ähm.
Die einfach sagen, wir wollen jetzt den den Markt, der ähm Pfad, Dienstleistungen, Vermittlungen.
Übernehmen, ist uns scheißegal wie. Ja, sie haben ja auch eine Zeit lang oder seit einiger Zeit vermitteln sie ja dann auch einfach Taxis, Hauptsache, die Leute nutzen Uber.
Das ist so diese diese Marktanteil äh Logik, ne? Das Unternehmen auf auf Marktanteil getrimmt werden, auch wenn sie keinen keinen Cent Geld verdienen, dann für ein Schweinegeld verkauft werden können. WhatsApp ist so ein Beispiel, ne,
Instagram ist so ein Beispiel, irgendwie halt eine Nische besetzen und da halt der einzige Anbieter zu sein und das äh das wird sich dann früher oder später.
Ähm schon ähm ausnutzen lassen diese Position. Und,
Dann halt so ein dieses dieses auf dieses Taxigewerbe zu gehen, wo eben ähm.
Wo eben starke Regulierungen sind, die eigentlich hauptsächlich zum Verbraucherschutz äh dort sind, zum zum, ne, Mitfahrerschutz.
Und dann aber so ein an dem Punkt zu kommen, dass man die Konsumenten halt da zu sich hinlockt, indem man dann eben andere Dienstleistungen bietet oder den Schwerpunkt bei den Dienstleistungen woanders setzt und die Leute auf einmal zufriedener sind,
Und gleichzeitig man den Leuten einimpft, ja, du kannst doch natürlich nicht erwarten, dass wenn hier ist,
dass du genauso wenig Geld zahlst äh wie wenn du halt irgendwie Sonntagnachmittag mal kurz um die Ecke fährst, ja? Also da da wieder so radikale,
Marktprinzipien einzuführen und das Ganze dann noch auf dem auf dem Rücken dieser Taxifahrer, die ohnehin halt ähm.
Tja, halt wirklich die Gearschten sind, ne. Das ist schon, also da da finde ich da da da gehen halt sehr, sehr viele ähm,
Wichtige Fragen für die Zukunft spiegeln sich in diesen Debatten wider. Und deswegen so diese, dass das jetzt so weit geht, dass da halt wirklich gewaltsame Ausschreitungen sind. Ähm,
In Frankreich, das finde ich schon überraschend und ähm ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange das noch dauert, bis hier die ganzen Airbnb Touristen.
Auch mit Missgabeln durch die Straßen,
geschickt werden, ja. Na ja.
Gibt, gab's doch mal diese Grafik äh in Berlin-Kreuzberg, so eine Straße? Äh oder so ein so ein Viertel, wo sie gesagt haben, okay, hier so, so und so viel ist auf ähm,
WG gesucht oder immoscout grade als Wohnraum zu vermieden und irgendwie das weiß ich nicht wie viel wie viel Faktor Xfache davon
wird halt auf Airbnb verhöhlt, ne?
Auch wieder so ein interessanter Aspekt. Ich meine, eigentlich eine coole Idee. Airbnb gibt's mal ein paar Tage deine Wohnung ab. Ähm und kriegst halt auch ein paar Euro dafür, ne. Dieses Couchsurfing ist, finde ich, das sehr viel sympathischere Modell, was auch den
Begriff des Sharing, dem, den Begriff des Sharings gerecht wird
Aber es gibt eben offenbar eine durchaus eine Nachfrage an Menschen, die halt was so richtig authentisch, gell, äh wohnen wollen,
und bereit sind dafür auch Geld auszugeben, das ist dann immer für die immer noch billiger als 'n als 'n Hotel,
und die Leute, äh die dann eben ihre Wohnung bereitstellen, äh freuen sich über ein Zubrot,
währenddessen wird halt irgendwie so ein Unternehmen, was eine relativ einfache Idee hatte über die ein, über diese Vermittlungsgebühren halt milliardenschwer, ne?
Weißt du jetzt auch nicht, ob das unbedingt eine positive Entwicklung ist, wenn wenn Menschen anfangen, am Ende ihren eigenen,
Persönlichen Wohnraum noch äh zu kommerzialisieren oder ihr mit ihr Fahrzeug äh zu kommerzialisieren und äh besonders schade finde ich natürlich, dass daran dieser Begriff äh Sharing irgendwie noch dranhängt, weil das ist halt nicht Sharing, ne?
Nö, passt überhaupt nicht.
Wenn ich mit dir Sherid Tim so, ich meine, du kannst ja mal was sharen von mir. Wir werden uns da sicherlich auf den Preis einig. Ich meine, so eine.
Total asozial, ne? Ich meine, das ist,
werde ich jetzt mal, jetzt lege ich mich noch weit aus dem Fenster. Das ist die, das ist die Vervollkommnung der Asozialisierung unserer Gesellschaft. Wenn du die, wenn du irgendwie das das Geben von von Unterkunft.
Und das mal ich nehme dich mal mit irgendwie na? Ich war letztens
fand ich ganz witzig. Da war das doch lustig. Da haben wir noch gelacht, kannst du auch sagen. Da standen wir mitm Auto, ich war Beifahrer, wir standen mit dem Auto an der Ampel und irgendwie, dass der äh die Fahrerin hatte sich in die falsche Spur eingeordnet und musste nochmal rüber. Er war irgendwie rechtsabbieger Spur, wollte aber geradeaus.
Und was macht man dann, ne, dann setzt man ja den Blinker links und schaut zu dem Fahrer neben sich und ne, signalisiert zu du, ich weiß, ich habe hier einen Fehler gemacht,
wärst du bereit, mich hier einzulassen? Und der machte nur so dieses.
Pinke.
Also den Kopf und machte das Symbol irgendwie, was zahlst du, ne? Wir haben natürlich alle drüber gelacht, ha ha, ne? Und dann sind wir gefahren, war alles in Ordnung, aber ich will nicht, ich will nicht wissen,
Wie lange das dauert, bis wir soweit sind? Ich meine, die Leute verhöckern inzwischen Parkplätze, ja? Ich fahre hier weg, was bist du bereit zu zahlen, wenn du meinen Parkplatz bekommst,
Also ich meine, das ist halt eine da, da da dringt der da wird dann im demnächst so einfach jede alles, was ich irgendwie als Ressource bezeichnen lässt, ähm.
Monetarisiert.
Monetarisiert. Und es gibt eine ganze Menge Menschen, die das äh völlig äh akzeptabel finden.
Genug Moneten haben.
Bin mal gespannt demnächst, wenn ich im Park sitze, ne und dann kommt der Pfandsammler. Und will mein Pfand haben, dann sage ich natürlich auch, verzahlt sie. Ich weiß genau, du kannst fünfundzwanzig Cent dafür bekommen. Gib mir zehn.
Mir zehn. Gib mir zehn. Mach's noch plus.
Ich musste die ganze Scheiße erst mal trinken.
Aber genau auf genau auf so eine Mentalität geht das jetzt raus, ne.
So eine äh auf so eine Mentalität läuft das hinaus. Und ich finde das eine enorm spannende Entwicklung, weil das äh natürlich äh letztendlich eine ist, wo am Ende wieder der größere Teil der Bevölkerung äh,
auf der Seite der Gearschten stehen wird und sich da eben äh eine sehr viel raubeiniger Umgang und sehr viel weniger äh Möglichkeiten für das äh für das Individuum am Ende erbieten werden.
Tja, vielleicht muss äh hier unsere Protestkultur auch äh von den Franzosen lernen, vielleicht kann man ja schon mal die Masais äh neu übersetzen.
Bin ein großer Freund des Musicals äh Leniserable, die schöne Hymnen, ja. Das Blut der Mertör wird die Wiesen Frankreichs wässern und so. Ja, ich meine, die.
Ja
Ja. Ich denke, bevor wir jetzt hier irgendwie äh,
widmen wir uns dann doch mal wieder wie schon zu Beginn dem Sonnenschein und den zwitschernden Vögelchen, oder?
So machen wir das, auf Wiederhören.
Bis bald, tschüss.